je pensais peut-être temps d'enchères
d'emplois aidés voulait m'embaucher mois
ils sont mais j'aime les anniversaires
[Musique]
c'est mon anniversaire et aux
commerçants
[Musique]
non non
excuse moi on fait quoi une fois qu'on a
fini avec les cagettes tu les prends et
tu l'aimés
j'allais chariot là bas ok merci c'est
bon mais qui t'a pas calculé s'en
souvient plus même moi un acte annuel de
chefs qui est pas reconnue mais pourquoi
il se porte à mon taf pas possible je me
foutais petite histoire voilà alors si
tu veux partir maintenant qu'il parte ou
bien plus tu veux que tes des pauses
bon allez vente
aulas
qu'il trouve son adresse d'accord
comme ça j'ai réussi le jeu montrant qu
pression cela faire tu vas dur moi ce
que tu as fait 100 m
à ce propos
[Musique]